all right kiki what do you got for me
buddy
hey how are you good
thanks for taking my call
so i recently
was with the woman we had a relationship
uh from last year april
and when i tried my best like she knew
she was exclusive to me uh but i was
with other
women during the duration i went
overseas came back we continued the
relationship everything went well i
vetted her for approximately one and a
half years she
met like 9 out of 10 of the requirements
that
especially the requirements for
being a potential good mother to my
children and having a she's a similar
ethnicity to me
uh follows a similar family called
and i thought i think but the thing is
we
recently like last week
ended things mutually or sort of took a
break and i another the opportunity to
have
more therapy sessions and sessions with
the psychologist because
she was demanding me to
do some religious practices
almost every day i was willing to do it
once a
week
or it would like
30 days fasting in ramadan but the same
way i stopped it was that i know myself
that i couldn't do like the religious
sort of thing
let me stop you for a second i need to
get some clarity so
you sent her to therapy because she
wants to impose her religious beliefs on
you
no
i don't send that to therapy so she was
doing last year therapy because of her
own personal problems or professional
problems or whatever and then she
stopped because
um
she wasn't sure if her work or her
profession was uh
added meaning to her life and she also
had an incident with an intern of hers
who fell
who gained emotional feelings for her
even though
uh the intern was married and had had a
child and that brought some conflict
with the hr department at her workplace
how old are you
28 how old is she
30. so she's older than you so that's a
bit of a problem why are you dating an
older woman
right
this young this younger woman the
intelligence level
it's not the same and her experience
and the level of same frequency that we
can communicate about i i've been with
like many younger women i have to tell
them i have to like coach them with
every little thing
and it kind of women are work you
understand that you know you have to you
have to
you know like set some boundaries right
like you understand that
yeah
so
sorry i just want to kind of deal with
one thing at a time here because i'm
kind of stuck on the whole
religious thing so what does she want
you to do
to
conform to her religion exactly
okay so the thing is that
i'm agnostic slash atheist and
well the community and people know me as
like being muslim or whatever and i was
ready to sort of change my practices or
whatever because it's a good woman who
i've sort of see a good woman will not
impose religious beliefs on you
that doesn't know this woman confirms a
good woman conforms to your frame she
doesn't impose her beliefs on you
right so what were these rules that she
wanted to make for you
so
she
okay so let me give you a background to
her
well i need to keep it short because i
got a lot of people waiting so i just
want to get to the point so what were
the rules that she wanted to impose on
you that you don't normally practice
so 30 days fasting in in ramadan one
once a one month out of the entire year
the second was we have a
religious friday prayer which we do
almost every friday which i don't do
these two practices
are you a muslim are you jewish
name muslim but i'm agnostic slash
atheist okay
yes
non-practicing
so i was willing to do these things to
have a potential good wife and children
and everything but the third one where
she stated that she expects me to at
least pray once a day with her and hold
her hand and then i knew i couldn't do
that so i stopped it i was quite quite
disappointed for a while because i
really thought that just this time just
this time like i had a potential wife
and i was willing to do the whole family
thing because
in which i've done like the whole uh
polyamorous thing and last year even i
had a
pivotal moment in my life where i
after
paulie polly is different from what guys
you know can run like a guy a guy can
run multiple women if he's high enough
value right you don't strike me as a guy
that runs a harem though
like you talking paulie like an open
relationship where she's banging a bunch
of guys and you've got girls oh no
exclusive from her and non-exclusive for
me but the thing is the ones i went out
on the weekend was one of my other
girlfriends and it literally uh sort of
caused her emotional turmoil for that
just about me and other women so
and then to deal with that afterwards
and to deal with those emotional
baggage okay so i was winning
here tonight like what are you asking me
here like you know let's boil it down
here so what do you want to know
i don't know if i'll like find another
woman who will fit into
having a good relationship with my
parents with my family as well you don't
even have a good relationship with her
though she's trying to get you to do
[ __ ] that you don't want to do
yes
and then you're saying like i don't know
if i'm going to find a good woman that's
going to have a good relationship with
like are you kidding me dude there's
eight billion people on the planet and
half of them are women there's four
billion women you're telling me you
can't find another woman that's not
going to tell you to pray every day
three times a day if that's something
that you don't want to do
you see what i'm saying right like
like on one hand you're saying that you
that you're
basically able to run a harem but you
can't run one chick that's like you know
imposing restrictions and beliefs on
your life
and she's having hissy fits whenever you
go out and do what you want and then
you're sending her to therapy right
right the quality of women out there
it's low it's bad
i mean they don't seek where do you live
man
south africa okay and how much money did
you make last year
uh in the ends
approximately
so here we don't actually calculate it
by
give it to me in us dollars
so approximately
what's that what's the exchange rate
just give it to me in us dollars rough
roughly
it's approximately
five
five last year
you made five thousand dollars last year
correct sorry i'm going to say that
again you made five thousand dollars usd
last year
is that money or is that annually
uh annually
you made five thousand dollars in total
last year
and you're talking about low quality
women dude you're a low quality man
you can't be expecting high like useful
women to enter your frame and want to
become the mother of your kids if you
only make five thousand dollars a year
you see what i'm saying right like if if
you want better options like if you want
to be able to choose from a wider pool
of attractive women that are compliant
that want to enter your frame that want
to be a mother i mean how the [ __ ] are
you going to pay for a family with five
thousand dollars a year
and does the family business uh i don't
know if you got the conversion right
dude
help me out here
rand so how much did you make and ran
last year
approximately
let's say hundred
let's say hundred
hundreds ran or a hundred thousand ran
a hundred thousand hundred thousand
rand
approximately six
sixty five thousand eight hundred and
fifty one united states dollars yeah
that's dude that's [ __ ] you can't like
you you're like
you're you're making all these
concessions have you read my book i've
talked about better tization through a
thousand concessions i know of the
concept from watching your videos you're
you're you're making concessions for a
chick because she's the only one that
you can talk to because you're not worth
your salt you don't have anything to
offer to women men are success objects
women are beauty objects you want a
beauty object that's going to enter your
frame and mother your children you
better be making some [ __ ] bank to
pay for a house and for all the needs
that the kids need right you need a car
you're going to need protection you know
you're going to need all these things
and she's older than you
so think about it dude
why do you always emphasize about like
the old and young does the intelligence
level not matter
compatibility
being able to communicate about common
topics when you're going to be 48 she's
going to be 50. women don't age the same
way that men do
ideally men should be dating 7 to 10
years younger than them
15 20 years is entirely doable leonardo
dicaprio dumps chicks when they hit 25
and he's in his 40s the only reason why
guys date older women is because they're
low-hanging fruit because they're easier
for them
it's the same reason why guys date
single moms because they're easier right
one of my friends is dating a single
wolf but i can't even tell him
you'll be so offended
right okay
let me just let me just get to the point
here though because i got a lot of
people waiting i don't want to get too
much of their calls you've got to sort
yourself out the reason why you're
limited to this one woman who's imposing
beliefs on you and restrictions and
religious you know convictions forcing
you to do certain things and then you've
got all these drama issues around and
all sort of stuff is because you're not
a high enough value guy you have to sort
out your life dude i don't know what the
cost of living is in south africa but i
would imagine that five
like five thousand dollars usd won't go
very far
right
see the thing is that we do you live
with your parents yes because it's a
culture like that as well okay
okay but you're 30 years old and you
live with your parents
and you and you're saying that the women
are garbage
you're a 30 year old man making 5 800
usd a year living with your parents
you want better options you need to
become a better guy
straight up
a lot better of a guy in fact
that's why your options are limited i'm
not going to argue with you bro i'm
going to let you go thanks for having me
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you